I brought a friend who is your friend
that's why I came in I've been I've been
trying to set this up for 10 years where
is your friend I got some music the man
works in us in a closet mr. Rickles you
don't have to give me a copy of book I'm
already read what is there something
Indian about should we thank you alright
I will read it Don Rickles wrote a book
yes Don Rickles is my here but I'm sit
down what are you doing to him you know
how it you don't remember we met years
and years ago when you had a convention
you're all wind-up member with radio
people rabbit stop that's the first time
I could talk to you yes
and then everybody said you got to be on
women I would say you gotta be on and
this guy this Greek has nothing else on
his mind when I read your book Don the
Don Rickles book now I'm reading it
right now you paint yourself as a loser
with women early on in your life you
know you know why and I think maybe I
don't know if you had that problem when
you were a young man look at me so what
happened was when you're the clown when
you have a class clown as you know yes
we did a class in the Navy Lea in my
whole life I was always the guy with the
jokes and if I don't go with him he's
gonna say everything you know brittle so
it was kind of tough I did all the jokes
the guys were out in the back of the car
and I was the driver right and I went
home you know put my slack myself in a
room put the covers over my head and
play games you spent a lot of time in
your book on Sinatra I mean you really
love this guy very much so figure it out
yeah why why did he why did he not have
you killed I mean you would say terrible
but you tell that greats I mean you
probably told it a million times but in
the book you write it very very well
thank you
the whole Sinatra story about when
you've you know you you're dating wasn't
going so great you finally get a date
with a girl and then you're there at the
club in Las Vegas you're eating dinner
and the girl turns and says I see Frank
Sinatra over there do you think you
could introduce me to Frank Sinatra and
you did the most brilliant thing in the
world can you tell that that's right
well you led up to that and she said I
said I said I know Frank you should
really so I went over to the table and
all of his security was around I said
Frank can I talk to you a minute
he said his bullet had he called me
bulletin she said yes bulleted what is
it I said Frank if you could come over a
couple of minutes and just say hi to me
with a girl I would skyrocket me I got a
good shot at hit a home run you know you
got but don't come over right away so I
went back and I was giving her that
cheap champagne and we were going to you
my darling an elipse were dancing and
you know my body was twinkling you know
and I try to be cool and she said look
who's coming and Frank's that's over it
had on this beautiful blazer in those
days with it I wouldn't ask God knows
darn how I and I got up at 1:00 not now
Frank can't you see I'm with somebody
but he had the security guys lift me
over their head carry me out and it's
written well in the book it says I came
talking doesn't yeah the book the book
is very very good I'm enjoying it and
because for me and I'm getting all
serious on you but really you are one of
the biggest influences in my life oh
thank you man it really is true I mean
when when I was a kid and I would sit
and watch you on the Mike Douglas show
specifically or I whenever I get to go
on Letterman I go if I could be half as
good as Don Rickles boy I would be I I
get the chills saying this to you
because I never saw anybody come out
there and be so entertaining and every
time that's why when I go in these talk
shows it is so important to me to be
entertaining because i sat
a kid there next to my mother was
droning on about her problems and then
Don Rickles would come on and drown her
out and make me laugh and it was so
magnificent it was the most beautiful
Symphony I've ever heard but it's such a
thrill to have you here really an honor
and I'm very very excited about your
book this business is how you how you
made it and you certainly didn't have it
easy and now you have a new new style
the thing with a new network satellite
radio it's great and and your young guy
yet and you got a lot of heavy thing
like I wish you the best thank you and I
look forward when I'm in New York again
if you ask me to come on and I could
just sit like this and have some time
we'll talk about the news Wilson will
talk about what's going I love it